bonsoir vive l'espèce merci d'être avec
nous la décision de facebook était
justifiée selon vous oui les événements
de 6 juillet son centre choquant et
dangereux et c'est le puissance de ses
plateformes comme facebook qui a donné à
dos notions de la capacité de mobiliser
les gens qu'ils ont attaqué les
capitales sssa l'événement déclencheur à
ce que pendant quatre ans facebook
twitter est lui a laissé le plafond
ouverte à un cas assez d'histoire et
après les 6 janvier
tout a changé et maintenant cette
bannissement permanente
c'est une signe que dans l'entente n'est
plus capable de augmenter son aide utile
ça montre tout de même de glace est le
poids de ces de ces géants d'internet
qui pas finalement décidé de fermer la
bouche de quelqu'un ou quelqu'un d'autre
en fonction de leurs croyances
finalement puisque ce ne sont pas des
juges et et et c'est vrai il y un danger
en démocratie quand vous avez les
monopoles dans le domaine qui décide
sans aucune réglementation dessous qui
se passe tout le monde utilise
maintenant c'est plate forme et ils sont
une arme puissante et je m'en doute que
qu'en grèce par le réglementer en dépit
des efforts tonnes répétition de
commencer un procès de ne sais pas à
quoi faire avec
les gars fin et bien sûr dans nos trente
était une personnalité puissante mais un
joueur et il va décliner et facebook et
à gogo et toute la puissance de
microsoft et ses géants d'internet
semble maintenant sans aucune
réglementation
lorsque les télévisions et les radios
sont bien réglementé donc il faut faire
quelque chose
c'est une décision clairement qui est
synonyme d'affaiblissement aujourd'hui
pour donald trump
oui il a annoncé la création de son
propre plate fin et ça lui a permis de
communiquer avec sa base s'était dit
regarder des 60 70 millions de votes
républicains qui aime bien mais oui ça
va diminuer son puissance de augmenter
ces chiffres parce qu'avant ce toiture
tout le monde peuvent consulter ses
tweets maintenant seulement légende qui
a donné une souscription à un abonnement
à cela
or les capacités et donc le grand public
n'a pas bougé avec ses messages comme
avant ça affaiblissent mais on va voir
dans les deux prochaines années
ce fait parce que louis continue à
diriger le jeu de pratique républicaine
il est le plus puissante et le parti
républicain est toujours le petit du
train ce qui fera finalement comment il
s'agit d'une entité privée c'est que
d'un entretien même pas de recours il
est banni un point c'est tout ce n'est
pas comme contient une décision de
justice et qu'on peut faire appel à non
exactement et essai et c'est une société
privée
tout le monde oublie que ce sont des des
sociétés privées habitude l audiovisuel
qui normalement tu as
dans les ondes qui sont réglementés par
le gouvernement mais si ce ces
plateformes c'est géant
ils ont joué un jeu se présenter en tant
que société privée prendre service
public et est le signe pour eux qui
soutiennent sans téléphone a pas de
recours en justice contre soi une telle
bannissement aujourd'hui risque de cette
décision ce qu'elles ne risquent pas
justement d'entretenir l'idée d'un
acharnement sur l'ancien président des
états unis
oui peut être ce qui se pense et la
société prisé et les grandes sociétés
aussi donc il y a eu qu'ils aiment 30 et
le qui trahissent et l'acharnement oui
c'est une beau monde pour décrire le
l'attitude des deux parties mais la
bataille n'est pas finie
ça n'a pas que commencer certains noms
connaissant donald trump peut-être pas
de glaciation propose de rester avec
nous pour continuer à commenter
l'actualité américaine puisque joe biden
a augmenté le plafond national de
réfugiés admis aux états unis alors que
donald trump avait fixé je vous le
rappelle un soto à 15000 pendant son
mandat chiffre historiquement bas à la
surprise générale joe biden avait décidé
de conserver ce seuil il est finalement
revenu sur sa décision après de
nombreuses critiques les détails d'un
maillage son blé avant de retrouver
notre invité la rupture avec donald
trump se fait de plus en plus nette aux
états unis joe biden a annoncé ce lundi
qu'il augmenterait le nombre de réfugiés
est admis aux états unis à soixante deux
mille cinq cents par an un plafond qui
avait été baissé à 15000 pendant la
mandature de donald trump et que le
nouveau président démocrate avait choisi
de maintenir malgré ses promesses
électorales
soulevant la colère dans son propre camp
complètement et totalement inacceptable
by john a promis d'accueillir les
immigrants et les gens de voter pour lui
sur la base de cette promesse soutenir
les politiques xénophobes et racistes
east de l'administration trump y compris
le plafond de réfugiés historiquement
bas et d'agrain gaulle et est tout
simplement inacceptable
tenez votre promesse face aux nombreuses
critiques
joe biden revient sur cette décision et
annonce vouloir travailler sur les
dégâts commis par son prédécesseur en
nouveau plafond national plus
hypothétique que réaliste du fait de la
reconstruction du programme d'admission
des réfugiés la décision est malgré tout
bien accueillis par de nombreuses
associations
nous ne serons pas en mesure d'atteindre
62500 et probablement même pas la moitié
de ce nombre cette année mais c'est un
signal important aux réfugiés au reste
du monde qui prouve que nous
reconstruisons notre programme que nous
sommes motivés pour atteindre un nombre
plus élevé mieux approprié un pays aussi
grand
aussi puissant et aussi accueillants que
le nôtre ce taux devrait augmenter
sensiblement en 2022 avec un seuil fixé
à 125 mille réfugiés par joe biden là
encore l'objectif sera difficile à
atteindre selon le président lui-même un
programme ambitieux qui fait partie de
l'adn des états unis selon le chef de la
diplomatie anthony blinken qui s'occupe
de sélectionner les réfugiés les plus
vulnérables dans les camps de l'onu
on retrouve un de glace ça y est ce qui
est toujours avec nous professeurs de
droit spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines clairement douglas y ait ce
joe biden a cédé on l'a vu à la pression
de l'ailé gauche
le son quand exactement le rhizome pour
laquelle il a cédé à cette pression
c'est qu'il a besoin des votes dans le
congrès au passif en législation le dit
insfrastructures mais je crois pas qu'il
va qu'il n'a réussi toutes les formes d
immigration qui l'a promis mais il en
ferait un peu de vie rendent à la gauche
parce qu'il a besoin de toutes les
bonnes petit le mans dans le sénat où
les gamins craig joue avec une seule
voix de majorité
clairement cette cacophonie sur ce sujet
c'est sa première erreur vis-à-vis de
son électorat
no il y là il a fait plusieurs gars le
propre dans le queens création lasser il
a annoncé son programme sans consulter
les potières critique et peut-être
maintenant il établit une bonne hygiène
de communication avec les députés
minorités et pro réfugiés mais c'était
un gars de communication plutôt que
politique
il a exposé sont des lieux de limiter
pour l'instant elle entrait des
nouvelles dans les états unis en cause
de la crise aux frontières avec les
chercheurs d'asile et les migrants et la
confusion dans le public américain c'est
les différences entre les réfugiés les
gens dans les capte au pnue partout dans
le monde et les migrants qui viennent à
leurs frontières et sans décision d'
apaiser la gauche du parti démocrate
peuvent lui coûter des votes dans les
étapes comme taxi ce qu'ils vont gagner
des votes
après le sens ça veut dire concrètement
que cette décision qu'il a prise
est ce qu'elle est clairement réaliste
on a vu que ce n'était pas aussi évident
que ça ce n'est pas simplement un effet
d'annoncé aujourd'hui le petit louis
mêmes et sont parce que les réfugiés ne
sont pas des chercheurs d'asile tout
seul à 6,1 procédures de vetting est ce
le nombre son petit 61.2 72 mille
personnes par an ces petits points près
de 300 milles
mais oui c'est une couac de
communication parce que actuellement un
avis polarisation sur le sujet des
nouvelles entrées en un mouvement
de droite aux états unis qui semblait
m'en veut plus des immigrés et des
réfugiés
et ce soir un sorte de gazon dans les
hommes de le coller clairement cette
bataille au livret a est remporté par
parle aile gauche en des démocrates à ce
qu'elles ont présage d'autres avec la
maison blanche selon vous nous
précisément un simple dans notre projet
des insfrastructures c'est lui qui
vraiment quand c'est presque deux
milliards de dollars dans une bille et
de toutes sortes et à commande dépend de
cette agence il vrai enjeu au fragment
tation nomme nombre de réfugiés
important symboliquement mais ça coûte
ça très peu et ça donne très peu de
ressources in au monde le congrès c'est
la capacité de amené à apporter de
l'argent de votre circonscription
hélas la gauche n'a pas beaucoup de
choses qu'il a demandé visiblement les
avec les systèmes de santé
mais non je pense que c'est une victoire
importante pour la gauche mais en
revanche il y aura plein des déceptions
à venir et à london bridge ne peuvent
pas être un président stable à la gauche
du parti démocrate
merci donc l'assiette sans d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur la france pour
commenter ces deux et deux actualités
aux états unis